[Música]
só temos mais um vídeo e eu ia fazer uma
coisa que vocês pedem muito que fazer
projetos muito mas mesmo muito simples
e aqui está um canhoto que no circuito
basicamente uma bateria um touro que
rodar amarelo compra online
se vocês não quiserem podem sempre
deixar alguma coisa e que não auditores
pensa que essa coisa foi avariada e
depois tentaram todos vocês tiverem ao
projeto e vamos dar também que um todo
porque completa maiores números vocês
não quiserem podem obrigar os carros
diretamente ou então podem fazer voz
produtor usando os dois coisas que eu
vou usar o pt que tem essas coisas em
vez por já que é muito bom para aumentar
a 30 e subir nos objetos
agora vocês não quiserem comprar podem
sempre nos alguns garotos para envolve
com fundac
depois podemos dizer com as coisas para
aumentar a frente seja para ficar com
aspecto berlingo passada pelo pacto
agora vamos cuidar
[Música]
i
lola
[Música]
você
a senhora facebook
[Música]
[Aplausos]